Let me explain our student debt
forgiveness program to all of you.
You, the good people who are having
your loans forgiven, you people
who paid your loans or never got
them in the first place, and then
you people who never even went to
college. We're forgiving up to 20
grand of your student loan debt.
Yeah, because of our.
Awesome.
Do not forget about us in November.
Okay. I know you're mad.
You struggled, you worked hard.
You missed a lot of opportunities to
get ahead in your professional
career, all to pay down your
debt responsibly, which proves
that you can do it again, for
them.
Remember, this is targeted relief
for working class people,
like a married couple making 240
grand a year.
You don't want them to suffer, do
you?
Let me get back to you later.
Are you willing to donate just $7
to help us win in November?
We've got to keep making progress.
Who knows? Maybe cancel some more
debt down the road, huh?
No,  we can't stop subsidizing
student loans.
Harvard's endowment is only $50
billion.
You don't want Harvard to suffer, do
you? This really isn't about you.
So just chip in, do your part, but
stay out of the way.
Hey, can you believe they canceled
Samantha Bee? Like what?
What ratings problem?
Everyone I know watches that show.
The important thing is that we
mitigate the damage that we cause
without ever addressing the root
cause of the problem.
You don't want Congress to suffer,
do you? Just put the money in the
bucket and leave.
No one wants to hear from you.
You just want people to suffer.
That's all we have to say.
Never engage with any substantive
argument or numbers or math
of any kind. It's only going to cost
about 300 billion or so
the first year.
We think with inflation, that's
going to feel like a lot less.
So if you guys were smart, you would
have taken a loan you couldn't
afford to go to college, but you
didn't. So pony up.
It's about two grand per taxpayer.
Put it in the bucket and leave.
Do you guys want to get smoothies or
something later? We need more people
in debt so they'll vote us into
office to get them out of debt.
Thought you people went to college.
Oh, please. You couldn't even spell
moral hazard.
Cool.
Awesome.
All right. November.
Of course it's constitutional
because of 9/11,
obviously.
Idiot.
Oh, I didn't see you there.
You know, you kids are the future.
That's why we're doing our best.
To make sure none of your actions
will ever have real consequences.
Except maybe voting.
Well, you know, we're working on
that, too.